Lật lụng này nó có thị khủng bao nhiêu cái máy nhà này ngọt trong biển nước luôn
Nhưng con đường hạn này rất là tâm đập đi bay giờ tại sao thịt giễn đây
Dọng nước đục ngọt rồi, cũng như là ở trong biển tay vậy
Từ trên cao, nhiều khu vực làng sơn như thất kê, chàng định, nasam, chìm trong biển nước
rất nhiều năm nay thì bay giờ mình biết thấy em, là con biển gặp nhiều như thế
Lứa ở đây chàng quả, nhiều người không kịt chạy hàng
Nhưng mọi người tại đi chuyện bằng phuyền bay ăn
Lạng sơn là một trong những địa phương trự thật hại năng gió mưa bảo gà ra
Mưa lụng kiến một người chết khoảng 3 in sấu trong nhà bị gặp
Chính quyền phối hợp với lực lượng kíu hộ sơ tháng người dân
Đồng thời tiếp tế lương thực cho các hộ dân bị cố lập
Theo chung tâm dự báo khí tưởng thị văn quốc gia, trong ngày 2,5 tự tháng tâm
Lạng sơn tiếp tục có mưa lớn, lượng mưa phổ biến 2,5 đến 3,5 mm
Cục bộ trên 5,5 mm
Mưa lớn tẹ mạnh quyết cơ ngập ũ, lũ, phạt sạch lợn đất